let's see if we can get a chuckle out of  this and then he wanted to know about my  family history I was like that's not  what this is about nothing to see  or 10 years ago my dad's a huge pain in  the ass so hopefully he'll wrap things  up this year  wrap it up too I said Dan I'm not  suicidal you don't have to worry about  it but people say life is too short I  think it's too long like  there's so many annoying people out here  and I just can't deal with it I said I'm  losing my patience uh there's there's  literally no joke here she's just  talking about how much she hates her  family and her own life and wants to die  and the cackling audience is laughing  yeah life is horrible I'm in despair  good one horrible life this is great  stuff